[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau mais aussi nos
reporters sur le terrain et sans plus
attendre voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 10 février 2020
est la réforme des retraites toujours au
coeur de la contestation sociale
responsables d'associations politiques
sociologues avocat ou comédiens ils sont
140 à avoir signé une pétition pour
demander la mise en place d'un
référendum sur le sujet
les avocats restent très déterminés ils
ont organisé une nouvelle manifestation
à toulouse aujourd'hui
[Musique]
9 108 personnes sont mortes en chine
depuis le début de l'épidémie du
coronavirus près de 40000 ont été
contaminées selon les autorités
chinoises
le président du pays appelle à des
mesures plus fortes et décisives contre
la maladie
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
s'inquiète et décide d'envoyer ses
experts en chine à pékin montrent les
dents l'ambassade de chine s'inquiète je
cite des mesures restrictives contre
huawei dans le déploiement de la 5g que
la france pourrait prendre notamment
contre away cette mise en garde
intervient après que l'opérateur
historique français orange est annoncé
la poursuite de sa collaboration avec
les équipementiers européens
nokia et ericsson à la filière vin reste
sur ses gardes
qu'elles soient françaises italiennes ou
espagnoles est les trois principaux
producteurs et exportateurs mondiaux
doivent composer avec le ralentissement
de la croissance économique chinoise
elle les taxes américaines mais aussi
une éventuelle crise sanitaire avec le
coronavirus de quoi qui était un secteur
déjà mis à rude épreuve
c'était il ya un an 220 salariés de
l'usiné de la papeterie arjowiggins
sécurité en seine et marne se retrouvait
au chômage certains d'entre eux
attaquent leur ancien patron pour
licenciement sans cause réelle et
sérieuse
depuis la liquidation judiciaire de
lusine a pas de plan social qui donne
droit à des indemnités et pas de
proposition de reconversion elle les
salariés sont ils devenus de simples
variables d'ajustement ce sera l'objet
de notre face à face à 21h30
[Musique]
responsables administratifs politiques
de gauche comédiens sociologue
syndicaliste avocats de nombreuses
personnalités lancent une pétition pour
réclamer un référendum sur le sujet de
la réforme des retraites
le but faire face au problème
démocratique majeur posé à part le
projet de loi
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
-
coc
oh
[Musique]
et
oh
on
[Musique]
alors le secrétaire général de la cfdt
laurent berger espère que l'hémicycle
prendra le temps d'examiner tout le
texte dans le même temps le secrétaire
d'état en charge des retraites laurent
un piètre hf qui a assuré que le
gouvernement ne passerai pas en force
écoutez il faut qu'à l'assemblée
nationale il y ait le temps pour
examiner tout le texte en profondeur
malheureusement la commission ne peut
pas aller au bout mais il faut que le
parlement examine tous les amendements
le volume d'amendements ne plaide pas
pour une solution évidente afin de faire
avancer un bon rythme l'examen de la
réforme
nous on est là pour travailler le fond
du texte il n'y a pas de 49,3 sur ce
sujet là et pour en parler nous sommes
avec jean baptiste eyraud porte parole
de l'association droit au logement dal
jean baptiste eyraud bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors vous êtes l'un des signataires de
la tribune parue dans l'humanité
pourquoi ce choix d'avoir signé écouter
est évident que l'association dans son
ensemble et tous les adhérents
d'associations soutiennent le mouvement
de protestation contre cette réforme
libérale des retraites et qui est aussi
un peu similaire à la réforme ou
réformes libérales qu'on a pu connaître
sur les apl et il faut savoir qu'il ya
de plus en plus de personnes âgées qui
sont aujourd'hui dans la rue et qui
souffre évidemment de l'insuffisance de
leurs ressources et qui par ailleurs ne
leur permettent pas de se loger
convenablement
donc pour nous cette question de 2
du des retraites qu'on a des cendres qui
permettent de vivre décemment sont
vraiment essentiel c'est c
la vie et celles à venir des personnes
âgées de ceux qui ont travaillé des
dizaines d'années et souvent dans des
conditions très pénibles difficiles et
malheureusement c'est bien cela qui
auront les retraites les plus faibles
et bien c'est leur avenir qui est qui
est inquiétant jeu et évidemment pour
nous c'est lié si les revenus des
retraités scellier a aussi leurs
conditions de logement
alors cette démarche votre démarche
votre tribune va au delà des partis
politiques car au fond un référendum est
également demandée par le rassemblement
national et aussi à l'effi est ce qu'on
peut parler d'un rassemblement dans la
division sur ce sujet les retraite
heureuse si vous voulez nous toute façon
on n'ira jamais manifestés et ont
n'apportera jamais notre soutien et même
oms on agira de manière constante si
vous voulez sur les les propositions
discriminante stigmatisante xénophobes
qui sont portées par
le rn donc pour nous tant mieux s'ils
s'opposent à la réforme des retraites
pourquoi pas mais c'est une évidence
d'abord cette initiative vient d'à
gauche
les forces qui sont mobilisés sont des
forces de gauche on n'a pas vu le
rassemblement national se mobiliser
réellement sur cette question là donc
qui pratique une politique assez
démagogique bon en disant bah ouais on
laisse faire tranquillement se fatigue
pas les voies vont tomber tout seul et
donc voilà je vous le dis parce que pour
nous
l'extrême droite est vraiment nos
ennemis principaux aujourd'hui puisque
nous défendons les mal-logés quelle que
soit leur nationalité et nous défendons
également le droit d'asile droit
d'accueil pour les réfugiés qui est
aujourd'hui considérablement battu en
brèche justement par extrême droite dans
toute l'europe
donc j'ai d'ailleurs sur la planète en
règle générale on a vu aussi aux états
unis donc pour nous oui ok très bien si
sûr rejoindre cette proposition
référendum pourquoi pas en tout cas pour
nous ces initiatives de gauche il s'agit
de défendre les valeurs les valeurs
sociales qui sont défendues depuis des
depuis 200 ans par et bien par la gauche
quoi la gauche française
il faut défendre les classes populaires
et une malheureusement pas le cas de
l'assemblée nationale en tous les cas
jean baptiste eyraud le temps presse le
débat parlementaire se poursuit
le conseil d'état a vivement critiqué
cette réforme ce sont autant d'éléments
qui vous font penser qu' on ne doit pas
retirer cette réforme est plutôt la
soumettre au référendum
absolument je pense que vu la
contestation que qui a soulevé la
réforme est une réforme qui touche très
largement et d'ailleurs qui va nourrir
aussi la spéculation immobilière
parce que voyez-vous la retraite par
capitalisation
elle va profiter aux fonds de pension
aux groupes financiers aux prédateurs
financiers tels que black rock et autres
qui investissent aussi par ailleurs dans
l'immobilier dans des villes comme paris
ou précisément la spéculation
immobilière sévit et qui vont profiter
de la montée des prix de la flambée des
prix immobiliers pour bien pour acheter
et gagner de l'argent un sur le dos de
qui gagne de l'argent au fonds dans la
spéculation une cantine quand ils
nourrissent la spéculation immobilière
tous ces groupes financiers et ses
spéculateurs et bien gagnent de l'argent
sur le dos des classes populaires qui
n'arrivent plus à se loger parce que les
loyers flambent
donc ils se retrouvent pour une partie
d'entre eux dans la rue en situation de
surpeuplement dans des taudis aux mains
des marchands de sommeil ou menacés
d'expulsion donc si vous voulez c'est ça
aussi c'est tout ce système là qui est
mis en place par le président macro qui
carnon 1 vise à faire des économies sur
le plan social d'une part et d'autre
part donner la main et enrichir les
riches donc c'est pour nous c'est pas
acceptable et évidemment cette question
de la retraite par capitalisation qui
viendrait se substituer à la retraite et
bien qu'ils aient assumé par 20 par les
travailleurs par les salariés et qui en
fait la mise en commun de la protection
sociale c'est à dire tous ensemble on
serre les coudes pour protéger les plus
fragiles c'est ça le principe de la
protection sociale en france et donc ce
pour ce processus là il faut absolument
le maintenir le sauvegarder sinon on va
se retrouver dans des situations comme
aux états unis où c'est des centaines de
milliers de sans abri et des villes qui
pourchasse et sans abri qui leur
interdisent de rester sur les trottoirs
d'ailleurs comme ça commence à se faire
en france donc de plus en plus de
personnes âgées qui se retrouvent
démunis qui vont être obligés de
travailler encore à l'âge de 70 ans 75
ans bon c'est terrible voire 80 ans
c'est terrible c'est terrible je veux
dire on n'a pas plus le droit de se
reposer dans la vie juste le droit de
travailler toute sa vie et de d'être
exploités enfin plus aucun moment de
répit
c'est terrible c'est terrible cet avenir
que nous prépare la réforme des
retraites c'est bien pour ça qu'il faut
absolument absolument mettre en place
obtenir ce référendum pour contester
cette loi inique et brutal qui qui
défavorise les personnes les plus
fragiles les femmes des migrants les
personnes âgées les personnes malades et
tous ceux qui ont travaillé durement
toute leur vie merci jean baptiste
eyraud d'avoir répondu à nos questions
directes sûrs et rt frange rappelle que
vous êtes porte parole de l'association
droit au logement
des étudiants de l'université de
nanterre ont manifesté ce matin devant
leur établissement pour protester contre
une série de mesures décidées par la
présidence de l'université
microphone à la main ils ont bravé le
froid et le vent pour dénoncer le lmd 4
un projet de refonte de l'offre de
formation des étudiants qui portent
notamment sur la validation des diplômes
le nombre des absences ou encore sur le
droit au rattrapage un projet qui
devrait être mise en place à partir de
la rentrée prochaine on à la présidence
de l'université de nanterre qui alors
depuis plusieurs mois prévoit un projet
qui s'appelle le lmd 4 et qu'ils
comptent faire voter aujourd'hui un
document qu'on appelle les mcc qui en
gros cadre nos la manière dont on valide
nos diplômes chaque année et cmc cette
année prévoit purement et simplement de
supprimer le droit à la compensation
intégrale de limiter le droit au
rattrapage à de remettre en cause
clairement la semaine de révision qui
sont des droits pourtant essentiel qu'on
a à l'université aujourd'hui pour chaque
année pouvoir valider nos années et nos
diplômes et qui en plus de sa prévoit de
limiter le droit au redoublement de
limiter le droit aux absences à de
limiter ce qu'on appelle le passage en
conditionnelle est en fait de mettre de
plus en plus de bâtons dans les roues
dans les post it et de valider
chacune de nos donne aux années et des
la jeunesse scolarisée
on sait que ça va précariser encore plus
les étudiants qui sont déjà dans des
situations précaires
il ya un droit aussi sur le cac vivendi
ce qui nous a taxés sur la question des
absences jusqu'à présent on avait droit
à trois absences pour 12 semaines
maintenant ils réduisent à deux absences
donc voilà pour les étudiants salariés
qui parfois loue des cours parce qu'on
sait très bien que le travail est un
facteur à côté de ses études c'est très
compliqué pour les étudiants situation
handicape les étudiants malades parce
qu'il faut savoir que ces absences
justifiées comprise de tous est logique
c'est aussi vraiment dupe
le but c'est que les étudiants et ou soi
tout seul mais deux pas du coup on va
redoubler d'efforts et individuellement
en fait parce que on n'a pas le choix et
que si on veut réussir
vous allez me sens il a fallu alors
vraiment laid ce qu'il faudrait deux
bises que nous on disait beaucoup la
scène ces dernières semaines quand on
intervenait en cours et où c'est qu'il
faut vraiment montrer que c'est en se
méfiant ce bateau il faut absolument pas
que ça fasse et il faut surtout pas que
parce que c'est ça c'est ce qu'il fait
part aussi cette logique de dubout je
vais vraiment travailler plus et c'est
s'attaquer toujours en plus haut aux
mêmes étudiants ceux qui travaillent
pour rendre une université super
élitiste le coronavirus poursuit sa
progression en francs que cinq nouveaux
cas le gouvernement à intensifier les
mesures de protection
air france klm a suspendu ses vols pour
la chine dans ce contexte les ministres
de la santé de la zone européenne se
réuniront jeudi
les précisions de bassins szczesny 72
millions de passagers en 2010 huit
dixièmes aéroport mondial deuxième
aéroport d'europe
on ignore souvent mais l'aéroport roissy
charles de gaulle et la première
frontière de france mais pas seulement
de l'espace schengen également avec ses
nombreux vols vers la chine l'aéroport
de roissy charles de gaulle et
l'aéroport d'occident le plus exposé aux
coronavirus devant des aéroports tels
que los angeles san francisco ou encore
melbourne conséquence de cette
catastrophe sanitaire le groupe air
france klm a décidé de suspendre tous
ses vols en direction de shanghai et de
pékin et ce jusqu'au 15 mars prochain
une reprise sera envisagée selon la
situation dans les semaines à venir
plus d'un mois détection du virus à one
en chine le bilan de l'épidémie s'élève
désormais à plus de 900 morts
principalement en chine est pas moins de
quarante mille cas confirmés la semaine
dernière en france cinq nouveaux cas
révélé cinq nouveaux contaminées dont un
enfant de 9 ans et cela faisait suite au
retour d'un ressortissant britannique
d'un voyage à singapour la ministre la
santé agnès buzyn s'est même rendu sur
place où une série de prélèvements et
d'examens sont encore en cours que ce
soit en haute savoie ou sur l'ensemble
du territoire
l'heure est à limitation de la
propagation à paris à l'hôpital bichat
on commence déjà à accueillir les
premiers patients présentant les
symptômes du corps de navires us pour
l'équipe médicale sur place c'est une
course contre la montre qui s'est
engagée pour limiter la propagation de
ce virus bruxelles accueillera jeudi
prochain les ministres de la santé de
l'ensemble de la zone de l'union
européenne
objectif discuter des mesures contre la
propagation de ce virus est de trouver
une approche coordonnée face à cette
épidémie mondiale et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct depuis exactement au
royaume uni avec barack baratte point
cagna expert en maladies infectueuses à
l'université d'exeter c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
dr baraquements gagna bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors le royaume uni considère le
coronavirus comme menace grave et
imminente
pourquoi une telle déclaration
aujourd'hui du ministère de la santé
avec des césar
je pense que c'est un problème global
c'est un problème qui va toucher la
plupart des pays du monde pour noir il
est temps que les nations du monde
entier collaborent afin de lutter contre
cette infection ensemble peut-être une
déclaration sur les propos du président
américain donald trump il estime que le
coronavirus va disparaître en avril avec
la chaleur quelle est votre réaction à
ces propos avec les informations
actuelles sur le coronavirus sortant
nous avons l'impression que avec
l'émergence de températures plus chaudes
deux journées plus longues avec moins de
promiscuité
il est possible que effectivement ce
sera la fin du tunnel
c'est un peut-être mais on peut
l'espérer en tout cas pour revenir aux
déclarations du ministère de la santé
est-ce que cela ne risque pas finalement
d'inquiéter voire à d'affoler la
population outre-manche comprends tout à
fait moi même et mes collègues dans le
pays entier travaillent très dur afin de
mettre en place
d'envoyer un message très simple et très
clair au public
c'est le suivant nous avons un problème
nous devons mieux travailler de concert
le royaume uni à une infrastructure très
performante et les autres pays européens
également un bon faut que nous sommes
dans une meilleure posture que l'afrique
tiennent mieux unis l'inde ou le
pakistan le bangladesh où l
infrastructure de santé ne sont pas
aussi bas par rapport à l'union
européenne
en tous les cas très concrètement
quelles sont les nouvelles mesures qui
vont être prises au royaume uni l'avion
poursuivre notre politique de
confinement c'est à dire que nous
souhaitons s'assurer nous assurer que
toute personne qui s est rendu dans un
pays où il ya eu une transmission des
infections avec ce corner virus sera
mise en quarantaine et nous appliquerons
cette période de quarantaine de 14 jours
plus tôt qu'une quarantaine quarantaine
tout en donnant des conseils pour
maintenir la bonne santé moi même mes
collègues dit faisons ce message si vous
vous sentez mal alors il faut que vous
vous confier vous-même notamment si vous
avez été en contact avec quelqu'un de
vraiment de chemins où était aux
alentours des pays asiatiques
une large alors même que ce virus
existait déjà il faut également appliqué
de bonnes mesures d'hygiène c'est à dire
se moucher avec des tissus en papier se
nettoyer les mains et se laisser chez
également c'est très important
faut également que vous l'aviez les
mains avant de manger
alors pourquoi le royaume uni a dit
adopter une attitude beaucoup plus
sévères que les autres pays européens en
tout cas comme ici en france est-ce que
d'après vous les autres pays européens
devraient eux aussi adopté ce type de
mesures à l'étude à elle est difficile
est de conseiller les gouvernements je
ne suis qu'à un docteur indépendante
revient qu'à l'université
je ne pense pas que
meutre approche est très comme plus
sévères que les autres pays européens
je ne pense pas que nous allons beaucoup
plus loin c'est peut-être une question
de langage la façon dont nous avons
communiqué sur la situation nos
procédures de confinement que ce soit au
royaume uni ou à l'union européenne sont
très similaires
alors il ya eu ces cas de citoyens
britanniques en france en haute savoie
tu coronavirus est-ce que selon vous la
france prend suffisamment de mesures
ce que je sais de la france je le pense
souhaite-t-on retenir le corps navires
ont seulement cuir hors de notre
territoire non confinement mais pas la
solution qu'il durera toujours nuls nous
aurons bientôt des cas sur notre
territoire est bon alors nous mais nous
assurer que les cas sporadiques sont
confinés aussi rapidement que possible
les traités qui lient la queue nous
retraçons les mouvements des malades et
que nous dit fonctionnent les bonnes
informations c'est la meilleure mesure
de contrôler pour nous alors pour
conclure comment est ce que vous voyez
la situation évolue et à quel moment
pour vous on atteindra le pic du
coronavirus je ne pense pas que nous
avons atteint ces jours alors la
diffusion de virus n'a commencé qu'à la
mi décembre et le taux de contamination
a augmenté fin décembre et nous ne
sommes qu'en février
malheureusement je pense que nous allons
voir de nouveaux cas et de la
contamination qui atteindra d'autres
régions du monde
mais ce que nous pouvons faire c'est le
contenir le contrôler autant que
possible ce corps navires us
cela permettra d'avoir des conséquences
graves sur la population que ce soit
dans l'union européenne et au royaume
uni
merci beaucoup docteur ben cagna d'avoir
répondu en direct à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
maladies infectueuses à l'université
d'exeter en allemagne la succession
d'angela merkel est compromise à
négrette 30
karen bauer dit à kaka renonce à la
chancellerie est la favorite dans gala
merkel jette l'épongé après la débâcle
de thuringe où une frange du parti de la
cd ou avait fait alliance avec l'afd
assez le mouvement d'extrême droite en
allemagne angela merkel à la tête du
gouvernement depuis 2005 n'a pas
l'intention de briguer un nouveau mandat
elle avait nommé à kaka il y a deux ans
à la tête du parti
pour adoucir la transition je savais à
l'époque que ce serait des moments
difficiles et les deux dernières années
l'ont prouvé pour ces raisons et dans le
but de renforcer la cd oui
après mûre réflexion j'ai annoncé ma
décision aujourd'hui devant la réunion
du conseil d'administration de la cd ou
et le conseil fédéral
je ne serai pas candidate à la
chancellerie
comme je lé déjà annoncées je me
chargerai moi même de trouver un nouveau
candidat qui fera avancer la cds et
l'ensemble du pays
le parti chrétien démocrate qui se
retrouve avec un problème de succession
à les précisions de l'analyste politique
ulrich bruckner à berne ceux qui sont
aux commandes comme le président du
bundestag wolfgang schauble eux mêmes
angela merkel essaierons de faire tout
leur possible pour calmer la situation
afin de mettre en place une succession
sans heurt sur les postes importants
la cds ou pourrait d'ores et déjà être
en train de prendre une décision
bien sûr il y aura des spéculations
pendant longtemps
c'est exactement ce que font les médias
ils sortent des noms mais comme souvent
la première tête à apparaître sera coupé
donc il est fort probable que le
candidat suivant on poste de chancelier
sera quelqu'un de parfaitement inconnu
actuellement et on poursuit avec le
deuxième et dernier jour du 33e sommet
de l'union africaine à addis abeba en
ethiopie une réunion qui regroupe près
de quarante dirigeants du continent et
qui s'achève ce soir principal sujet de
ce sommet la crise libyenne alors gérer
jusqu'à maintenant par l'onu le chef du
conseil de paix et de sécurité de
l'organisation s'est exprimé cet après
midi sur l'intérêt de l'union africaine
dans un futur plan de paix en libye
want is because une fois que la
cessation des hostilités sera
officiellement signé en voulons nous
joindre à l'onu dans une mission
d'évaluation en libye il lit bien tous
évalués watts tout pour évaluer ce qu'il
est nécessaire de superviser pour
s'assurer que la cessation des
hostilités est respecté par le trio un
excellent c'est l'onu elle-même qui a
besoin de nous maintenant yoann a jugé
le 7 10 points depuis en huit ans
itunes donc que l'union africaine peut
certainement apporter sa contribution
car il s'agit d'un problème africain
nous avons une certaine sensibilité
cullin autre nom peu des abattements de
notre aph et dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du déploiement de la 5g en
france alors que la chine hausse le ton
et met en garde paris contre
d'éventuelles restrictions
puis nous reviendrons sur la surtaxe des
vins français à l'occasion du nouveau
salon professionnel elle des vins et
spiritueux qui se déroule à paris restez
avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le week-end geoffroy deux frères animé
par leur passion pour l'eau ont décidé
d'emprunter les routes de la soie sur
les traces des premiers échanges entre
les civilisations
en quatre mois de la chine à paris et
parcours sur leur side car plus de 15000
kilomètres à travers l'asie centrale et
l'asie mineure pour revivre l'évolution
du commerce mondial et son impact sur la
ressource en eau
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes c'est diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
c'est quoi cette merde
puis l'année dernière la quantité de
drogue saisie a augmenté d'environ 490
drogue
on m'a arrêté en pensant que j'étais
membre d'un gang
robin priorité suspectés de délits
[Applaudissements]
ici la plupart des femmes courageux sera
longue peine de prison
nous avons inventé ce concours pour leur
remonter un peu le moral je veux certes
indiqué je suis déterminé à remporter le
titre miss talavera bruit
[Musique]
ils sont élevés dans un seul but
ils ont un super pouvoir il commence à
s'entraîner dès le plus jeune âge
huit mois de formation intense
ce sont des rats est il sauvé des vies
humaines
on a construit
attention attention la tête mais
qu'est-ce qui fait nous allons découvrir
le meilleur de cartes
[Musique]
on a construit ça doit être
attention on a construit
et le bon tu le vois oui il est en
construction on la construit avec six
mois d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez les 20h30 heure
française
pékin met paris en garde contre des
mesures discriminatoires à l'encontre de
huawei l'ambassade de chine s'inquiète
je cite à des mesures restrictives
contre huawei dans le déploiement de la
5g que la france envisagerait de prendre
des précisions florian lambert
la tension monte au sujet de la 5g alors
que le groupe iliad maison mère de
l'opérateur free souhaite que le
gouvernement clarifie sa position sur
les équipementiers autorisé pour le
déploiement de la 5g l'ambassade de
chine en france a mis en garde paris ce
dimanche sur d'éventuelles mesures
discriminatoires qu'on trouvera way
pékin se dit inquiet et choqué le
président emmanuel macron et d'autres
hauts responsables français ont
réaffirmé à plusieurs reprises que sur
la question de la 5g la france ne
prendrait pas de mesures
discriminatoires contre un pays ou une
entreprise spécifique ni n'exclure et
huawei donc si les informations
susmentionnées des médias français
s'avèrent exacts c'est visiblement
contraire à l'engagement pris par le
gouvernement français fin janvier
l'union européenne avait ouvert
partiellement sa porte à huawei pour
développer la 5g défiant ainsi les
etats-unis qui accusent l'équipementier
d'espionnage au profit de pékin
mais cette mise en garde de la chine à
la france pourrait avoir des
conséquences à l'échelle internationale
sur le déploiement de la 5g la france la
chine serait obligé de faire machine
arrière sur le développement de la salle
j'ai bien joué et ça permettrait aux
entreprises européennes avec tout
bénéfice pour l'europe de mutualiser
leurs besoins et de mutualiser le
déploiement de la salle j'ai un peu
moins bien peu plus cher mais deux
autres opérateurs hexagonaux sfr et
bouygues telecom utilise notamment des
équipements de huawei sur le réseau
actuel leurs annonces sur la 5g sont
attendus dans les semaines prochaines
après validation par les autorités
françaises
et pour en parler claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau claude
blanchemaison bonsoir choix merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation pour
commencer qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé de ce communiqué qu'est ce que
vous en retenez bassin petit peu
insolite parce que c'est une déclaration
du porte parole de l'ambassade de chine
à paris alors pourquoi le porte parole
pourquoi aujourd'hui et pourquoi en
france
ça pourrait être une déclaration de
l'ambassadeur ça pourrait être un peu ça
pour être dans un autre pays européen
d'autant plus que l'on sait que la
bataille fait rage avec les états unis
le grand titre du film the times
vendredi dernier c'était sur la première
page une colère homérique de monsieur
donald trump dans une conversation
téléphonique avec le premier ministre
britannique
parce que le premier ministre
britannique a entrouvert la porte à
huawei mais avec des précautions
puisqu'il s'agit d'un sujet qui peut
être sensible pour certains secteurs
paris n'a pas stigmatisé wei wei paris
n'a pas de disputes ouverte pour le
moment avec washington
cela dit probablement que l'ambassade de
chine à paris a choisi ce moment parce
que orange il ya une dizaine de jours a
indiqué et orange c'est important parce
que c'est l'opérateur comme on dit en
france historique c'est l'ancien france
télécom de ne faire plus tôt à faire
avec nokia avec ericsson qui sont ses
partenaires habituels et qui ont équipé
la 2g la 3g la 4g alors pourquoi pas la
5g surtout qui est des équipements
communs est assez logique et assez
naturelle mais effectivement devant nous
il ya le choix de wig ya le choix
d'autres opérateurs et je pense que
l'ambassade de chine à paris a voulu
marquer qu'eux
elle attendait un petit peu le
gouvernement français au tournant le
communiqué est un peu menaçants
d'ailleurs puisque il indique que de
ceux sans le dire ouvertement que des
mesures de rétorsion pourraient être
prises contre les opérateurs européens
pas français puisqu'ils pour les
fournisseurs
plus exactement d'équipement européen
nokia ericsson
il n'y a pas de français puisque notre
opérateur vedette d'il ya quelques
années
s'appeler alcatel et qu'il a été racheté
par nokia
par conséquent c'est une affaire qui
devient une affaire européenne puisque
la menace porterait sur des fournisseurs
de matériel européen est d'ailleurs la
commission s'en préoccuper puis la
menace porte aussi sur la relation
stratégique entre la france et la chine
qui sont excellentes en matière de
coopération sur les centrales
électronucléaires sur l'aviation et sur
les questions spatiales et donc la
mention de ces trois secteurs fait peser
une une vague menace la chine pointe
notamment du doigt le traitement
différent entre les entreprises
chinoises et européennes considérées
comme un jeu site protectionnisme
déguisé c'est le cas pour vous c'est une
accusation sans fondement finir bas pour
le moment c'est sans fondement c'est
concerne la france puisque simplement la
france en effet après une loi et un
décret d'application qui font que les
opérateurs devront soumettre leurs
projets de contrats avec des
fournisseurs de matériel 5g à une
autorité de régulation qui est assez
proche pour les télécommunications du
secrétariat général de la défense
nationale la sécurité ce qui est assez
logique parce que ça touche à des
questions sensibles et que chacun sait
qu'en matière de télécommunications tout
le monde écoute tout le monde
et lorsque huawai dans son communiqué
promet qu'il n'y aura pas de backdoor
c'est-à-dire de porte de derrière pour
écouter pour pour
aspirait des données évidemment il ya
toujours une backdoor ne serait ce que
pour des raisons de sécurité puisque les
services nationaux doivent pouvoir avoir
accès à ses communications sur
autorisation du juge pour anticiper les
risques d'attaqués terroristes
donc ce communiqué en même temps mais le
projecteur sur les points délicats
autre point délicat il indique que
huawei a établi a ouvert un laboratoire
de recherche de sécurité en grande
bretagne mais bon ça veut dire que par
départ différent s'il n'y en a pas un
front si pourquoi n'y at il pas en
france mais qu'il promet à la france et
qu'il est prêt à signer un papier
suivant lequel il n'y aura pas de bague
d'or c'est à dire de porte dérobée pour
avoir accès à ces données
en tout cas on comprend que le sujet de
la 5g et très important alors qu'est ce
qu'il implique
et pourquoi c'est un enjeu aussi
stratégique merci d'un jeu stratégique
parce que les data comme on dit les
données sont maintenant la source de la
puissance
celui qui a accès à tous et à toutes ces
données a évidemment un pouvoir
considérable et notamment en matière
économique
c'est vrai en matière de en matière de
sécurité en matière militaire
mais c'est aussi vrai en matière
économique
parce que si on a accès à toutes les
données d'une entreprise ces données de
recherche de projets le nouveau produit
évidemment c'est un avantage
considérable et c'est pour ça que je
disais tout à l'heure que dans le fond
tout le monde écoute tout le monde
donc la question c'est est-ce que les
tuyaux est ce que la technologie le why
why peut être neutre oui dans une
certaine mesure pas plus et pas moins
que les autres quel est le rôle des
opérateurs au fond c'est plus que
justement ces tuyaux qui qui vont passer
alors les opérateurs installent les les
les relais naturellement et puis
fournissent les services aux
utilisateurs
que ce soit des administrations les
entreprises ou des particuliers
d'ailleurs donc l'opérateur en
choisissant le fournisseur en effet
d'équipement fait un choix important
et en effet on peut considérer
raisonnablement que les opérateurs
européens présentent plus de garanties
qu'un opérateur lointain mais en effet
ça reste à démontrer
ça reste à démontrer d'autant plus qu'
on apprend dans la presse que les
américains sont en train de se demander
s'ils ne vont pas demander à cisco leurs
entreprises dans ce secteur des
télécommunications de racheter nokia et
pourquoi pas de racheter aussi l'autre
entreprises européennes pour fait pour
avoir accès en effet assez à sedata et
pour faire pièce à la concurrence
chinoise qui est sérieuse parce que le
matériel chinois est de très bonne
qualité et il est beaucoup moins cher
que le matériel européen pour conclure
quelle attitude la plus probable va
tenir la france après cet agacement
chinois l'attitude de la france au
programme une attitude européenne
c'est-à-dire une attitude mesurée
il n'y a pas de raison de prohiber
weiwei il n'y a pas de raison de
l'exclure des marchés de façon
systématique
mais en effet il est logique qui est
l'instance de régulation qui est en
fonction de la destination des
équipements décide s'il est opportun de
choisir plutôt des entreprises comme
nokia ou les entreprises comme moi
ouailles
évidemment les éléments techniques et
économiques feront partie de cette
appréciation donc
contrairement à ce que font les états
unis où elle y met pas blacklisté
systématiquement en europe mais il est
assez logique que les autorités de
régulation est un oeil sur la chose et
puis je crois que why why comme toute
entreprise développe son lobbying auprès
des centres de décision et que c'est un
peu curieux de prendre l'opinion à
témoin par un communiqué public sur une
affaire qui finalement est très
politique mais aussi très technique
merci beaucoup claude blanchemaison
d'avoir à apporter votre éclairage sur
ce plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
expert en relations internationales
c'est aujourd'hui que s'est ouvert le
salon du vin de paris à la porte de
versailles l'événement devrait réunir
près de 30000 visiteurs venus du monde
entier pour célébrer les vins français à
des vins français directement menacés
par les prémices d'une guerre
commerciale entre les états unis
l'europe et la france
une de nos équipes est allé à la
rencontre de vignerons regarder il y a
comme des arômes d'amertume au salon du
vin de paris
donald trump a décidé d'augmenter les
taxes sur les vins français non
pétillants de 25% et ce depuis le 18
octobre dernier des représailles aux
aides financières accordées par l'union
européenne à airbus au détriment de
boeing est en prévision des prochaines
taxation des entreprises digital
américaine les fameuses gars femmes qui
réalisent des bénéfices peu ou pas
imposer en france et en europe
les 72 % des vignerons indépendants
français qui commercent avec les
etats-unis sont déjà fortement touchés
par ces mesures
une petite enquête dans notre réseau dès
la fin du mois de décembre c'est à dire
deux mois et demi après le début de
l'application de la taxe mais c'est déjà
paraître 20 millions d'euros de pertes
en trésorerie et 100 millions d'euros
sur les neuf prochains mois
voilà donc un manque à gagner important
en terme de réseau mais aussi des parts
de marché qui tranquillement se referme
puisque chaque fois que novell ne sont
pas vendus ce sont des veines d'autres
destinations pour ton pays dans le monde
qui prennent notre passé a contrario les
vins pétillants comme le champagne ne
sont pas encore taxé mais l'inquiétude
plane sur les gros comme sur les petits
producteurs
on est pris dans un imbroglio en plus
qu'il ne nous concerne pas en fait
parce que nous on touche aucune
subvention on touche rien enfin voilà là
on est on est pris au piège qu'on ait
des victimes
la conséquence est des pertes et puis
surtout de devoir se réorienter de leur
devoir réinvestir sur deux pays sur
lesquels j'avais pas forcément envisagé
au départ d'un vestiaire joseph côte
nick vient chaque année des états unis
acheter du vin en france
ce caviste américain redoute de voir ses
fournisseurs se détourner vers d'autres
marchés et surtout de perdre ses
consommateurs ces 25 % de taxes
représentent toute ma marge
cela ne pourra pas être compensée il y
aura une répercussion sur les
consommateurs
nous n'achetons plus de 20 il y aura un
impact sur les ventes et sur nos
capacités à conserver les emplois
américains et français du secteur font
front commun car ces mesures n'ont pas
du tout l'effet escompté
cette taxation en fait
depuis le 18 octobre
avait rapporté moins de taxes inclus les
25% que l'année précédente avec les
importations
ça a été le premier point le deuxième
point les estimations économiques qui
ont été faites pour les sociétés c'est
entre 85 milles et 125 mille pertes
d'emplois directs
il ya déjà quelques clients qui ont
licencié une deux trois personnes mais
c'est quand même des chiffres
extrêmement important d'ici une semaine
de nouvelles taxes américaines
pourraient bien venir frapper plus
durement le marché du vin on parle d'une
hausse de 50 à 100 % cette mesure
qualifiée de désastre par les
entreprises américaines du secteur
risque d'obscurcir durablement le ciel
du monde viticole et pour en parler nous
sommes avec thomas montagne président de
la confédération européenne des
vignerons indépendants thomas montagne
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation le salon wine bar in
fine et vinexpo pardon se déroule donc
on le disait dans un climat morose entre
les taxes le corps d'un virus le bric
site
bref est ce que ce type de salon est un
moyen une occasion de relancer les
exportations
est ce que ça fonctionne oui en général
ça fonctionne assez bien et je pense
qu'il faut dire sur ce salon c'est que
pour la première fois nous avons en
france un salon unitaire l'ensemble de
la france viticole se retrouvent à paris
alors que jusqu'à présent ces dernières
années nous étions éclaté en trois
quatre cinq salons différents ce qui
était ce qui rendait les choses très
compliquées notamment pour les
importateurs au grand export pour venir
nous voir alors que vous aviez en
allemagne un grand salon unique à
düsseldorf qui drainait énormément de
monde donc nous sommes très contents
d'avoir ce salon maintenant unitaire qui
se tient à paris justement alors
effectivement salon interprofessionnelle
toutes les interprofessions française un
vin de loire côtes-du-rhône bordeaux
alsace vous êtes tous réunis vous venez
de le dire c'est quoi l'idée derrière la
stratégie c'est l'union fait la force
certainement je pense que il faut que
nous apprenions mais c'est valable pour
d'autres secteurs en france de
l'économie française nous apprenons
davantage à chasser en meute ou
simplement profiter économie génère 2
de d'échelle et puis je vous le disais
vraiment avoir plus de poids pour faire
venir nos clients jusqu'ici on les fait
venir une fois peut-être deux fois par
an en france on les fait pas dire quatre
fois par an en france notamment une fois
à montpellier autrefois à bordeaux
autres une fois en val de loire et c'est
donc c'est c'était injustifié
alors je le rappelle quelques chiffres
en novembre aux états unis les
exportations de vins français se sont
effondrées de 44% par rapport au mois
d'octobre après ces femmes staxyn de 25%
de l'administration trump est ce que
l'heure est à la panique qui aujourd'hui
chez les vignerons français panique
c'est peut-être bien grand mot mais une
forte inquiétude
évidemment parce que ceux qui ne se vend
pas à l'export se retrouvent sur le
marché français ipso facto ce sont des
équilibres qui sont assez fragiles on
est on est sur un marché peu élastique
donc une légère surproduction enfin sur
quantité d'offres par rapport à la
demande peut faire chuter les cours de
manière assez importante et émettre
toute la pyramide mal oui alors vous
lisiez tout l'interprofession réunit
justement pour pour contrer un petit peu
ces difficultés là qu'elles sont
finalement les autres pistes à mettre en
oeuvre pour vous pour relancer les
exportations de vins français
écoutez si on parle sur cette histoire
de taxes d'abord ce qui nous paraît nous
absolument inadmissible et ce que nous
ne voulons pas voir se reproduire jamais
c'est d'être les victimes collatérales
les otages
la viticulture le monde viticole
français et européens finalement parce
que ça touche plus largement que la
france
est prise en otage par des choses qui ne
l'étaient pas totalement en l'occurrence
aucune histoire qui date de 2004 une
plainte devant l'om c'est concernant du
des problèmes entre boeing et airbus
excusez moi mais c'est pas notre affaire
nous vous avons le sentiment finalement
de payer des conséquences d'une guerre
qui n'est pas la vôtre
ah oui dommage collatéral voilà ce que
nous sommes et ça nous va pas du tout du
tout le président macron pourtant on le
sait est un amateur de vin davantage que
les [ __ ] précédent d'ailleurs est ce
que vous sentez soutenu aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement par le chef d'état
écoutez je ne sais pas parce que ou oui
mais oui et non parce qu'il y avait
aussi ce problème de taxes gafa dont on
savait que ça allait poser que trump
allait réagir d'ailleurs il a réagi et
ce faisant il a obligé monsieur macron a
reculé
dont acte pour le moment mais c'est
quelque chose qu'ils reportaient d'enfin
on parlait là d'une taxe non pas de 25%
mais de 100% sur un certain nombre de
produits franco français donc c'était
cet invraisemblable
parce que ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
je sais pas seulement le coût de la taxe
la limite 25 % peut-être que certains
sont en capacité en la partageant avec
l'importateur de la deûle à payer mais
on perd des parts de marché
parce qu'on est on s'éloigne des des
linéaires en nous on a quand même aller
j'irai à peu près 80% de nos vignerons
en france je parle réunion les vignerons
indépendants adhérents ont honte eu à
choisir à les lire la valise ou le
cercueil c'est à dire soit entre une
prise en charge pour partie ou totalité
du surcoût de 25 % soit la commande est
reporté sine die voilà ce qui se passe
actuellement
quand une commande est reporté jeudi
d'autres que nous l'apprennent pour
l'instant ça se passe en dehors d'europe
c'est ce sont des australiens des
chiliens des argentins et c'est qu'ils
bouffent des parts de marché part de
marché c'est difficile à gagner ça se
perd très vite mais pour la regagner
après c'est compliqué donc c'est pour ça
que nous nous demandons avec insistance
et de manière très rapide est ce que
l'europe problèmes européens puissent
mettre en place un fonds bed qui
permettent de passer ce cap rapidement
et puis au delà de ça bien entendu il
faudrait que au niveau européen encore
une fois on soit en capacité de répondre
de manière unitaire est mis au point un
monsieur très justement vous êtes vous
président de la confédération européenne
des vignerons indépendants
il y aura vous le disiez tout à l'heure
un autre salon du vin ce sera à
düsseldorf cette fois ci un sérieux
concurrent finalement et vous appeler à
l'unité justement entre les vignerons de
toute l'europe pour faire face à la fois
aux taxes de trump mais aussi aux autres
problématiques commerciales
oui bah c'est un petit peu le but de
tout syndicat est donc la confédération
européenne que je préside ces gens
représentent quoi j'en compte peu près
200 mille petites entreprises très
petites entreprises au niveau européen
ça fait ça fait quand même du monde
on a treize états membres qui sont
adhérents à notre confédération
le vigneron indépendant c'est qui c'est
celui qui fait tout de a jusqu'à z dans
la filière c'est à dire qui il a cet
agriculteur qui a ses vignes qui les
cultivent c'est un transformateur qui va
faire du vin avec ses propres raisin et
c'est un commerçant qui va mettre ce vin
en marché donc il a un métier très vaste
le corollaire c'est que il produit
beaucoup de valeur ajoutée dans les
territoires où il est et il a un fort
impact donc au niveau environnemental au
niveau du maintien des territoires
demeure en bonne état environnemental et
économique
donc quand on nous touche nous quand on
touche nos petites entreprises on
attaque vite quelque chose est
fondamental dans les territoires ruraux
pour ça qu'on est important en fait la
souffrance de ces vignerons indépendants
elle est surtout en france où partout en
europe
elle s'exprime tels des différentes mais
sur le sujet qui nous préoccupe la les
taxes curieusement alors que bon faille
à cinq pays qui se de quatre ans dans
quatre pays qui sont touchés par les
taxes sur le vin notamment la france
l'italie de l'époque en principe mais ne
supporte pas actuellement c'est à 25%
pour autant je sais je sais que mes mais
mes confrères et amis italiens sont
aussi dans l'expectative et perdent
aussi des parts de marché parce que vous
savez que le business horreur de
l'incertitude et trump est à tout moment
décider de modifier cet état de chose il
y avait maintenant c'est plus le vin
français cinéma italien un container de
vins italiens qui se trouverait entre
sur la mer en transit pour les états
unis pourraient être reparti à zéro taxe
arrivé là-bas avec 25 % taxe je vous dis
pas le bazar pour payer un autre mot
donc évidemment
pour les italiens aussi il va les
importateurs américains sont en stand by
pour le moment il y a eu si le break
site on en a beaucoup parlé est ce que
vous avez une visibilité vous comme
vigneron pour la suite pour les
exportations futures en direction du
royaume uni pas vraiment je sais comme
tout le monde que l'on nous promet un
ordre de stabilité en local
immédiatement après j'espère quand même
qu'avec nos amis anglais on va réussir à
s'entendre non c'est pour nous français
c'est partir mais important puisque
entre les états unis et numéro 1 pour
notre marché et les angles numéro 2 on a
du pain sur la planche et si on rajoute
le problème chinois vous évoquez tout à
l'heure avec le coronavirus évidemment
notre quoi être inquiet alors justement
pour conclure face à ces inquiétudes est
ce que vous comptez vous mobiliser pour
en appeler à l'europe ou gouvernement
surtout à l'europe je pense c'est un
problème européen
et oui oui je le redis hors de question
pour nous pour la viticulture me plante
je pense pour l'agriculture en général
que nous soyons quasi systématiquement
les victimes collatérales de problèmes
qui le dépasse totalement
voilà merci beaucoup thomas montagne
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes président de la
confédération européenne des vignerons
indépendants
merci à vous aux etats unis justement
les élections pour la primaire démocrate
se poursuivent prochain rendez vous
demain mardi dans le new hampshire
la semaine dernière les réserves les
résultats dans l'état de l'iowa on
donnait deux candidats au coude à coude
le sénateur bernie sanders et le jeune
outsider pitt bouddha biega la bataille
fait rage pour savoir qui sera dans la
course pour la prochaine présidentielle
mathilde heureux gagnants qui de bernis
ou de pit pour représenter les
démocrates
l'enjeu est de taille le candidat
désigné par la primaire aura
l'investiture pour la prochaine échéance
présidentielle
d'un côté il y à bernie sanders sénateur
du vermont
âgé de 78 ans il a de l'expérience et il
la revendique
son seul défaut être considéré comme
trop socialiste pour la gauche modérée
américaine
et nous avons tous deux combattu cet
agenda et l'establishment corporatif a
dit trop radicales et l'establishment
politique a dit trop radicales et
l'establishment médiatique a dit trop
radical
mais vous savez ce que les gens du new
hampshire ont dit ils ont déclaré qu'il
s'agissait d'un assez bel ensemble de
propositions face à lui le caucus de
l'iowa à placer un candidat surprise
pitt beauty jet 38 ans ancien maire
d'une ville moyenne de lyndiane à avec
un programme progressiste mais plus
modérée il attire les foules à ses
meetings
dimanche plus de 18000 personnes ont
assisté à son discours anna choix du
jamais vu pour une primaire démocrate
le candidat y voit un bon présage pour
le caucus de mardi dans le new hampshire
êtes vous prêt à tendre la main à tous
ceux que vous connaissez à les appeler
dans ce mouvement qui va tourner la page
êtes vous prêt pour ce lever de soleil
sur la shoah ou la présidence de donald
trump et en arrière-plan
êtes vous prêt à écrire l'histoire mardi
ensuite aller gagner en novembre new
hampshire
je pense que vous allez m'aider à
devenir le prochain président des états
unis et je travaillerai chaque jour pour
vous rendre fiers les primaires
démocrates ne sont pas exemptes de
quelques couacs le score très serré
entre sanders et beauty jay a nécessité
un recomptage dévoue à plusieurs
reprises et chacun a revendiqué la
victoire
il y a en tout cas un grand perdant joe
biden l'ancien vice-président de barack
obama était pourtant le grand favori de
cette primaire dans l'iowa il n'est
arrivé qu'en quatrième position loin
derrière sanders et beauty jake à moins
que le scrutin dans le new hampshire ne
réserve d'autres surprises à et dans
quelques instants nous reviendrons sur
la réforme des retraites avec les
avocats qui ont décidé de poursuivre
leur mouvement de grève
puis nous parlerons des propos tenus par
ségolène royal sur la mutation des
professeurs pédophiles en outre-mer est
des députés ultramarins demande
l'ouverture d'une commission d'enquêté
parlementaire
restez avec nous sur rt france est cuite
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coups politiques n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
alexandre je faisais direct vous êtes
vous déjà dopé
il n'y a jamais de ma vie vous pensiez
que la sphère du dopage en russie était
terminée pour vous trompiez les
documents sont arrivés et que j'ai
ouvert le dossier et j'ai eu
l'impression d'être recouverts de boue
la participation des athlètes russes aux
compétitions internationales est en jeu
cela concerne notamment des événements
tels que les jeux olympiques de tokyo et
la coupe du monde de football au qatar
c'est ma médaille je sais que je les
gagne honnêtement je ne vendrai jamais
comme il ya quatre ans le laboratoire
antidopage de moscou est au centre de ce
scandale alors qui a modifié la base de
données d'échantillons des sportifs et
quel rapport cela a t-il avec grigoriy
rodtchenko
ils ont pu remplacer des résultats
négatifs par des résultats positifs
comme si l'athlète avait déjà consommé
des substances interdites pour
l'approcher par la suite et le faire
chanter pour de l'argent
comment
bâtie c'est de notre pas seulement le
cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france chaque année 150
tonnes de déchets électroniques sont
amenés au ghana c'est un travail
dangereux mais nous avons besoin
d'argent
c'est pourquoi nous continuons à le
faire pour les pays développés
c'est le moyen le plus simple et le
moins coûteux de se débarrasser de ses
déchets toxiques et c'est qui c'est une
bombe à retardement si nous ne trouvons
pas de solution dans les deux ou trois
années à venir ce sera encore pire et
pour les habitants sur place
cette décharge est un aller simple vers
la mort cela veut dire que cette partie
d'accra sera tellement pollué
maintenant il faudra normalement poser
une clôture autour du site couler une
chape de béton dessus j'avais créé un
autre tchernobyl à accra
fabien six ans il y avait tous ici
qu'elle parle de verdure de la ville la
zone était habité par plusieurs familles
mais maintenant avec vous pouvez voir
vous même comme ça
round sol de 700 à 1000 familles seront
évacués de force aujourd'hui ou demain
quelques unes seront jetés dehors
[Musique]
parfois quand je marche sur le char ben
je vois qu'ils fument par endroits mais
dessus ton pied glisse aux médias que le
charbon est l'objectif principal
tout le monde veut du charbon les gens
sont traités ici comme des rebuts
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous il est 21h merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'information tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi à 10
février 2020 la réforme des retraites
toujours au coeur de la contestation
sociale responsables d'associations
politiques sociologues avocat ou
comédiens ils sont 140 avoir signé une
pétition pour demander la mise en place
d'un référendum sur le sujet les avocats
restent très déterminés ils ont organisé
une nouvelle manifestation à toulouse
aujourd'hui c'était il ya un an 220
salariés de l'usiné de la papeterie
arjowiggins security en seine et marne
se retrouvait au chômage certains
d'entre eux attaquent leur ancien patron
pour un licenciement sans cause réelle
et sérieuse
depuis la liquidation judiciaire de
lusine pas de plan social qui donne
droit à des indemnités et pas de
proposition de reconversion elle les
salariés sont ils devenus de simples
variables d'ajustement ce sera l'objet
de notre face à face à 21h30
[Musique]
non
en france la colère des avocats ne
faiblit pas nouvelle manifestation
aujourd'hui à toulouse
l'ordre des avocats de dijon soutient
également le mouvement dans une lettre
ouverte adressée à la garde des sceaux
après un mois de grève le conseil
national des barreaux avaient voté
vendredi la poursuite du mouvement et
donc de la mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites le gouvernement a
pourtant entamé des discussions sur la
reconnaissance de la pénibilité avec les
avocats et les syndicats pour trouver
des solutions concrètes à des
discussions loin d'être suffisante
puisque dès 10 heures ce matin des
avocats du barreau de toulouse se sont
donné rendez-vous dans le quartier de
saint cyprien
les avocats du bureau de toulouse réunis
en assemblée générale extraordinaire le
mercredi 5 février 2020 rappelle que le
droit de grève est un droit fondamental
dont l'autorité judiciaire est garante
rappelle que tout justiciable a droit à
un procès équitable avec l'assistance
d'un avocat indépendant dont la liberté
de parole est garanti rappelle que le
mouvement de grève national des avocats
vise précisément à préserver cette
indépendance et pour caroline mécary
avocate au barreau de paris cette
mobilisation est avant tout un enjeu
démocratique pour tous les français
écoutent et là rappelle quand même que
la réforme des retraites pour les
avocats ça veut dire qu'un tiers de la
profession risque de disparaître il ya
donc un enjeu de survie à titre
professionnel mais ce qui veut dire
aussi si on regarde un petit peu plus
loin le fait que les gens les plus
démunis n'auront plus accès à un juge
c'est donc bien un enjeu démocratique
keita qui est à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui et
donc nous sommes en train de regarder la
manière dont nous allons poursuivre la
mobilisation
mais croyez moi que le conseil national
des barreaux après cinq semaines de
grève est encore appelé à la poursuite
de la grève de façon unanime c'est que
ça ne faiblit pas et que ça n'est pas
partagée donc maintenant la balle est
dans le camp du gouvernement en réalité
est ce qu'ils vont commencer à nous
entendre et non pas à faire semblant de
nous entendre
en nous disant votre augmentation la
cotisation c'est vos réserves qui vont
les payer je rappelle que nos réserves
c'est quoi ces les cotisations que nous
payons actuellement et que elles n'ont
pas pour objet de compenser une
captation de ces réserves elles ont pour
objet de servir les pensions de tous
qui ont pris leur retraite est
normalement c'est au moins jusqu'en 2000
80 et pour en parler nous sommes avec
leïla hamzaoui avocate présidente
d'honneur de l'union des jeunes avocats
à paris
leila alaoui bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on vient
d'entendre caroline mécary elle parle
d'un enjeu démocratique pour tous les
français où la rejoignent et je la
rejoins parce que cette réforme des
retraites qui frappe durement les
avocats et le contexte compliqué des
relations avec le gouvernement et en
particulier avec le ministère de la
justice s'inscrit dans un contexte plus
global où on fait ça n'arrête pas aller
réforme qui porte atteinte au ministère
d'avocat et à la possibilité pour les
justiciables d'avoir accès à un avocat
et donc cesser on a l'impression d'un
rouleau compresseur effectivement qui
essaye de se débarrasser de cette
profession donc au fond la poursuite de
la grève que vous avez voté elle est
aussi le signe d'un mal plus profond de
votre profession d'un mal plus profond
et d'un mépris très profond jeu très
simplement dans le contexte de
négociation où les avocats n'ont cessé
de dénoncer l'absence de réelles
concessions et de réelles avancées du
gouvernement
on a appris à quelques jours de notre
de notre dernière réunion avec le
gouvernement que il venait d'inscrire
dans un projet de loi une disposition
qui permettait aux assureurs de réduire
les honoraires versés à l'avocat dans le
cadre des dispositifs de protection gu10
jury juridique
donc on est dans un vraiment dans une
volonté de porter atteinte à la capacité
de l'avocat accompagner ses clients
est ce que vous pensez aujourd'hui
souffrir d'une image de privilégier
c'est ce qu'on peut entendre un parfois
dans la population
est ce que cette image c'est celle du
gouvernement et du chef de l'état à
votre endroit selon vous alors c'est les
éléments de langage qu il pilonne sans
arrêt pour mais qui sont au fur et à
mesure moins perçu comme cela parce que
la réalité elle est tout autre on a
beaucoup fait de pédagogie pour
expliquer la situation des avocats qui
est excessivement compliqué pour un très
grand nombre de confrères mais aussi
parce que cela dépasse cette question
aujourd'hui
si tous les libéraux parce qu'il n'ya
pas que les avocats tout là tous les
métiers de proximité tous ces métiers du
savoir qui accompagne les gens partout
en france sur les territoires sont dans
la rue et sont en difficulté c'est pas
parce que ce sont des nantis qui
préservent leurs droits mais parce que
aussi au delà de ça il préserve ceux de
leurs clients de leurs patients et et
ceux des français qui ont besoin de ces
métiers pour pouvoir continuer à vivre
correctement dans ce pays l'enjeu
démocratique que vous évoquez tout à
l'heure la ministre a donné des gages
pas de baisse des pensions pas de
doublement des cotisations ni même
d'augmentation brutale tout en
soulignant que le gouvernement a indiqué
qu'il était prêt à retenir d'autres
scénarii lissant davantage encore cette
hausse
et puis enfin le maintien de la caisse
de retraite des avocats qui restera
l'interlocuteur unique de la profession
s'est toujours pas suffisant pour vous
mais surtout c'est rien en réalité
alors c'est bien habillé c'est bien
c'est bien marketé on a fait des heures
et des heures de réunion avec leurs
services et malheureusement tout cela
est faux c'est à dire que le lissage qui
nous est proposé c'est est évoquée par
ma consoeur dans une interview il nous
et il nous est proposé de nous couper
nos réserves pour les affecter à payer
nos cotisations dons qu'ils ont proposé
d'enlever ce qui appartient à nos
retraités pour l'affecter à payer nos
cotisations mais les talus
de fait aucune concession c'est à dire
qu'il ne perd pas un centime ils
prélèvent bien ses cotisations majoré et
puis il ya tout un tas de situations
qu'on apportait alors attention les
pensions ne sont absolument pas garanti
il n'y a pas de système notre caisse et
dépourvue de tout pouvoir et elle ne
peut plus collectés donc elle ne peut
plus assurer les pensions donc en
réalité ce sont des moi j'appelle ça des
propositions de papier il n'y a rien
derrière
dans ce contexte avec ses propositions
que vous dites de papier est ce qu'une
sortie de crise à court terme est
possible sachant que le dialogue est
toujours pas rompu le dialogue n'est pas
rompu néanmoins il ya un préalable qui
est cette question de la possibilité
pour les assureurs d'imposer les
honoraires à l'avocat dans la loi azap
qui est qui vient d'être d'être présenté
le dialogue n'est pas rompu
le conseil national des barreaux a voté
qu'il souhaitait ne pas fermer la porte
mais exigeait des propositions certaines
la sortie de crise elle m'apparaît
compliqué dès lors qu aujourd'hui les
revendications élémentaires qui sont les
nôtres et notamment même celle d'avoir
des chiffrages précis c'est lui l'auteur
fiable voilà cela aujourd'hui ça n'a pas
été fait on a donné en 6 juin et en
juillet à leur demande si cas type qui
correspondent à la typologie de la
profession d'avocat ils nous ont indiqué
qu'ils nous les donne en septembre puis
en novembre et aujourd'hui on les a
toujours pas ils ont inventé des cas on
en a beaucoup parlé le fameux françois
et puis marion mais qui n'étaient pas
des cas réels
aujourd'hui on n'a toujours aucune
simulation un simulateur a été mis en
ligne par un syndicat et le gouvernement
lui a demandé de le retirer
immédiatement pierce que les résultats
étaient catastrophiques et n'arrangeait
pas gouvernement un simulateur fiable de
par le gouvernement ce serait un premier
pas déjà pour vous je pense que ce
serait un premier pas mais ça ne
changerait pas la question de fond qui
est de la teinte économique qui est
porté à la profession d'avocat et à tous
les libéraux par le dispositif tel qu'il
est fait qu'il n'a pas pris en compte la
particularité économique des libéraux et
le fait qu'ils payent leur propre outil
de travail leur propre rémunération
leurs propres charges sociales leur
propre protection sociale qui ne peuvent
pas assumer la charge que le
gouvernement entend leur faire peur à
leurs demandes massives de
voie de mise en liberté multiples points
de droit soulevée à chaque audience la
mécanique en ce moment judiciaire est
mise à mal on constate c'est la méthode
pour vous c'est une méthode efficace
pour vous faire entendre selon vous la
méthode elle est efficace en ce sens que
les avocats portent avec les magistrats
et les greffiers le personnel de justice
à bout de bras un service public qui est
mourant qui n'a pas de moyens on en
parle de d'avocats qui sont obligés de
fournir de la papeterie haut magistrat
et aujourd'hui ce que démontre ses
actions massives c'est que quand
l'avocat nous n'acceptons plus de faire
le travail de l'état à la place de
l'état
la machine se grippe ça ne fonctionne
plus donc oui c'est efficace parce
qu'aujourd'hui on l'entend et on a vu
madame belloubet a ainsi pour ainsi dire
déraper samedi en nous enjoignant nous
invectives en disant de cesser le
mouvement parce que ce n'était plus
tenable
et oui donc cela démontre combien
l'avocat est essentiel au service public
de la justice avec les autres acteurs de
justice et oui nous devons maintenir la
pression et nous la maintiendrons
maintient non ce qui a été voté
tant que nous n'avons n'auront pas un
dialogue réel est vrai sur l'ensemble de
ces questions avec nous à arcore de six
semaines six semaines de grève c'est un
rôle est mort du jamais vu pour votre
profession qu'est ce qu'on peut craindre
est ce qu'on peut prendre en craindre un
engorgement dans les mois à venir dans
l'est dans les tribunaux un engorgement
alors c'est beaucoup évoqué
l'engorgement 1
je vous donne un exemple aujourd'hui sur
les cours d'appel par exemple sur les
procédures de cour d'appel
on est à 2 à 3 ans de délai pour avoir
une date d'audience
donc si vous voulez le moi je veux bien
que les avocats portent la
responsabilité de la totalité de la
défaillance du système judiciaire mais
je suis pas sûr que ce soit notre
mouvement qui soit la raison des
difficultés de l'engorgement
la réalité c'est que c'est toujours être
chose c'est la paupérisation du service
public de la justice mais oui je pense
que on va vers quelque chose qui se
durcit les barreaux travaille
actuellement à d'autres formes de sortie
et de mobilisation parce que il y a
aussi une grande proximité avec les
greffiers et les magistrats qui sont
pour la plupart assez soutenant on
essaye d'innover mais il est très clair
que la détermination des avocats et sans
faille et qui ne lâche rien pour
conclure il y aura des répercussions
pour les justiciables
alors ce que nous essayons de faire
justement c'est qu'elle n'en ai pas pour
les justiciables
aujourd'hui les actions les plus les
plus massives ce sont les actions de
défense massives dont vous avez
peut-être entendu parler avec lesquels
les justiciables sont assez d'accord
puisque ses actions ce qu'elle montre
c'est que quand on peut vraiment faire
fonctionner la justice les justiciables
sont beaucoup mieux défendu donc en
réalité c'est cela effectivement
sur lequel il faut appuyer merci
beaucoup les lames ça oui je rappelle
que vous êtes avocat de présidente
d'honneur de l'uja paris c'est l'union
des jeunes avocats
toujours en france cette information pas
est passée quasiment inaperçue ségolène
royal auditionné à huis clos à
l'assemblée nationale cet après midi à
katia technique et nous apporte quelques
précisions sur place une délégation de
députés d'outre-mer a auditionné
aujourd'hui ségolène royal à 17 heures
en cause les propos polémiques qu'elle a
tenus sur les professeurs pédophiles
petit retour en arrière de janvier 1997
à mars 2000
ségolène royal était déléguée à
l'enseignement scolaire
en janvier elle a été invité à discuter
de la sphère gabriel matzneff sur bfmtv
rmc
elle a expliqué qu'à l'époque la
pédophilie était tabou et qu'avant on
mute et discrètement si possible dans
les outre-mer ces propos ont évidemment
fait réagir les populations dans les
territoires ultramarins
l'association des maires de guyane a
demandé à emmanuel macron des précisions
des vérifications qui s'imposaient et
puis également de disculper les
professeurs qui ne serait pas impliqué
dans ce scandale
de son côté ségolène royal a minimisé
ces propos parlant plutôt de rumeurs et
le député guyane et prg gabriel serville
a interpellé le ministre l'éducation
jean michel blanquer
lors des questions au gouvernement et le
ministre a répondu selon lui il n'existe
aucun élément probant pouvant corroborer
les insinuations de ségolène royal nous
avons aussi interviewé le député
communiste sébastien jumel qui a suivi
cette affaire qui pourrait s'avérer être
un nouveau scandale d'état
d'une certaine manière il ya un roland
colonialiste vinci on envoie des
enseignants pédophiles en outre-mer
parce que c'est loin et qu'on sait pas
quoi en faire vous imaginez la honte de
la république que ça représente
et
et donc ça justifie que madame royal
s'explique si elle a des éléments elle
doit les livrets et sexe ça implique que
le gouvernement fasse le point sur la
réalité de cette situation des députés
d'outre-mer ont donc demandé l'ouverture
d'une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
il souhaite également l'audition de jean
michel blanquer
leur objectif protéger les sept cent
mille élèves dans les territoires
ultramarins et pour en parler nous
sommes avec mansour kamardine députés l
ère de la 2e circonscription en de
mayotte montsûrs kamardine bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors une audition cet après-midi de
ségolène royal à huis clos par le bureau
de la délégation outre-mer composé de
onze membres
sait-on comment cela s'est passé
pourquoi à huis clos est ce qu'il va y
avoir une enquête
alors c'était à huis clos parce que
madame royal a su été ça le soit ainsi
et évidemment elle n'a pas été
suffisamment bavarde sur la question et
compte tenu de ce qui a pu être dit et
des l'émoi qu'a suscitée ces
déclarations qu'on suscitait ces
déclarations nous avons décidé
effectivement de solliciter une
commission denquête et la raquette et
déjà d'ores et déjà sur le bureau de
richard ferrand parce qu'elle s'est fait
ces accusations ces propos sont d'une
extrême gravité
l'outre-mer ne peut pas être la poubelle
des tout ce qui ne marche pas sur le
territoire métropolitain
alors justement pourquoi la grande
majorité des buts et ultra marins at
elle été écartée de cette audition on
comprenait donc on n'a pas été de les
capter madame royal a souhaité avoir à
huis clos et je crois que le bio il ya
accédé pour lui permettre de venir
s'expliquer donc elle est venue elle a
dit ce qu'elle avait à dire
et compte tenu de ce qu'elle a dit nous
avons considéré que nous ne pouvions pas
rester là et qu'il fallait sans doute
faire toute la lumière sur cette
question et si vous voulez moi je peux
aussi affirmé à la barre le sens de
madame royal que ces propos en tout cas
s'agissant de mayotte ont un semblant de
vérité parce qu'à mayotte aussi nous
avons connu il ya quelques années
quelques cas deux toits des enseignants
comptait affecter à mayotte et qui
finalement ont été rattrapés par la
justice et je dois vous avouer que les
sanctions prononcées par la justice
était bien en déça des des blessures
subies par les victimes parce que
lorsque les parents envoient leurs
enfants adéquat c'est pour être éduqué
et non pas pour subir des agressions
sexuelles
ce que vous nous dites ce soir c'est que
effectivement il y a eu à mayotte dégâts
des cas de pédophilie de 2,3 de deux ou
trois enseignants à dans des
établissements scolaires
il faut pas généraliser je crois que
nous avons des enseignants de très
grande qualité mais il est vrai qu'il ya
eu un certain nombre des gens qui ont
été mutés ici et que la justice à
rattraper ceux des questions d
pédophilie tout comme moi je dénonce
également les incertains une certaine
légèreté dans l'affectation d'un certain
nombre d'enseignants qui pourrait
s'avérer aussi radicaliser qu'on envoie
sur le territoire de mayotte
actuellement et donc il faut faire
attention comme je disais l'outre-mer ne
peut pas être là la poubelle de tout ce
qui ne marche pas au plan national alors
de son côté jean michel blanquer à
ministre de l'éducation lui dit qu'il
n'y a pas d'élément probant est ce que
vous allez sentiment qu'on
voudraient étouffer un éventuel scandale
d'état monsieur blanc kéraudy aurait dit
une chose différente les affirmer des
déclarations différentes savourer
surpris c'est qu'il faut aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment l'état le gouvernement
vers que les choses soient totalement
transparente c'est d'accepter
ils ont la majorité c'est d'accepter
effectivement la mise en place de cette
commission denquête ya donc voilà on
pourra aller ouvrir un certain nombre de
des dossiers pour vérifier ce qu'il en
est réellement
est ce qu'il ya une véritable omerta sur
ces sujets dans l'éducation nationale
selon vous mais bien sûr comme je vous
disais comment peut-on expliquer qui est
des gens par exemple des gens qui ont
été surpris ou convaincu notamment par
des décisions de justice devenue
définitive qu'il soit encore reconduit
dans leurs fonctions affectés à d'autres
endroits et souvent toujours outre
ouvert sans qu'il y ait des sanctions
une surprise allez vérifier par exemple
si ces personnes qui ont été condamnées
par la justice à mayotte ont été écartés
de l'éducation non ils ont bénéficié des
mutations ils sont partis sous d'autres
cieux outre-mer où il fait encore très
beau alors justement autour de vous et
plus généralement en outre-mer quelles
sont les réactions de la population
qu'est ce qui domine c'est quoi la
stupeur après les propos de ségolène
royal sans doute là la préoccupation le
dégoût surtout aux vie du fait que l'on
cherche à minimiser à étouffer
au lieu d'aller vers la recherche d'une
dot delà d'une totale transparence
nous demandons la vérité je crois qu'il
ya un besoin de vérité un besoin de
transparence et c'est un sujet à mon
avis qu'il faudra si nous voulons
apaiser les ultramarins il faudra que
l'état joue la totale transparence
vous parlez d'un besoin de vérité besoin
de vérité qu'on a entendu
dans l'institution de l'église plus
récemment des personnalités dans le
monde du sport qui ont été touchés ont
demandé à d'éventuelles victimes de
sortir du silence
est ce que c'est un appel que pourrait
passer l'éducation nationale pour vous
un appel aux victimes en disant de deux
de sortir du silence
moi je pense déjà que l'éducation
nationale doit pouvoir favoriser la mise
en place de cette commission denquête à
partir de là moi je moi je ne vais pas
de si vous voulez je ne veux pas de
d'explication je ne veux pas de 2 voilà
ce que je souhaite c'est que la lumière
soit faite
parce qu'une fois que la lumière c'est
la fête est bien à l'avenir
on évitera ce genre de scandale
qu'elle nous donne en sont pour contre
notre poste pour conclure vous êtes
confiant la commission denquête va
pouvoir exister je vous avoue quand je
vois les déclarations qui sont faites
quand je vois y compris même la latitude
de madame royal je ne le pense pas mais
il appartiendra aux élus d'outre-mer aux
populations de thon est d'exiger c'est
une exigence un d'exiger cette cette
transparence où on a effectivement de la
manière la plus je dirai simplement
possible ou alors il faudra attendre que
les les événements l'exigent c'est que
serré malheureux donc moi je pense qu'
il est de l'intérêt de la république de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour que cette
transparence se met à jour
merci beaucoup mon sourire kamardine je
rappelle que vous êtes député les
républicains de la 2e circonscription de
mayotte au salvador maintenant crise
entre le président n'a ebooks et les et
les députés ces derniers refusent
d'approuver un projet visant à allouer
109 millions de dollars aux forces
armées du pays et pour mettre la
pression le président salvadorien a fait
hier irruption à l'assemblée en
compagnie de militaires et de policiers
les précisions de françois tyszkiewicz
lourdement armés et munis de gilets pare
balles des militaires et policiers
entrent dans le parlement salvadorien
dernier épisode de la tension croissante
entre les députés le président naguib ou
qu'elle est en cause
un prêt de 109 millions de dollars
visant à équiper les forces armées pour
lutter contre les mara le nom donné aux
gangs salvadoriens
le président du salvador avait exigé que
l'assemblée siège en session
extraordinaire ce week-end afin
d'approuver le projet ce dimanche
il a donc fait irruption dans l'enceinte
parlementaire entouré de militaires un
fait sans précédent depuis la fin de la
guerre civile en 1992
juste avant ce coup d'éclat n'a ebooks
et les s'est exprimé devant ses
partisans
si ces bons à rien n'approuve pas cette
semaine le plan de contrôle territorial
alors nous reviendrons ici dimanche
prochain nous demandons à dieu à nouveau
la sagesse et disons dieu vous m'avez
demandé d'être patients mais ces
scélérats ne veulent pas travailler pour
le peuple
une présence de militaires dans le
parlement qui a suscité l'inquiétude de
la communauté internationale
pour amnesty international elle rappelle
les époques les plus sombres de
l'histoire du salvador
peuplé de près de 6 millions cinq cent
mille habitants
le salvador est considéré comme l'un des
pays les plus dangereux au monde avec un
taux annuel en 2019 de 35,6 meurtres
pour 100 mille habitants à la tension
monte encore d'un cran entre damas et
ankara en syrie chats les deux camps
s'affrontent dans la région d'idlib où
cinq nouveaux soldats turcs ont été tués
par les forces de bachar al-assad selon
ankara
le pays de prix du président et chef des
hyper doan qui affirme aujourd'hui avoir
neutralisé son soldat la turquie
réaffirme qu'elle maintiendra ses postes
d'observation dans la région
conformément à l'accord signé avec damas
en 2018 alors qu'une délégation russe et
présentant ankara pour des pourparlers à
la turquie met en garde le gouvernement
syrien contre de nouvelles offensives
si l'accord continue d'être violée nous
avons un plan b et un plan c nous
maintiendrons nos postes d'observation
dans le cadre de l'accord conclu
néanmoins si un obstacle se présente
nous affirmons clairement que nous
mettrons en place le nécessaire à l'iran
n'hésitera pas à riposter si nécessaire
ce sont les mots du directeur de
l'organisation iranienne de l'énergie
atomique ali akbar salehi lors d'une
réunion sur la sécurité nucléaire à
vienne alors que le secrétaire américain
elle
j a exhorté l'iran à s'expliquer sur de
potentielles traces de particules
d'uranium sur son sol le directeur
iranien de l'énergie atomique a lui
accusé les états-unis d'infliger des
dommages à son peuple et de soutenir des
groupes terroristes
malheureusement l'administration
américaine n'a pas encore repris ses
esprits en reconnaissant la réalité du
terrain fait continue de faire du mal à
notre peuple ainsi qu'à la population de
toute la région tout en créant et en
soutenant des groupes terroristes tels
que l'état islamique
nous demandons à l'iran de coopérer
pleinement avec l'agencé internationale
de l'énergie atomique pour surveiller
inspecter les installations de l'iran et
pour répondre à toutes les questions de
lagence concernant l'exactitude et
l'exhaustivité de la déclaration de
garantie de l'iran est impératif que
l'iran fournisse une coopération
opportune pour expliquer la présence de
particules d'uranium dans un lieu non
déclarés et j'espère que tout le monde
peut convenir que l'iran doit savoir que
la communauté internationale soutient
pleinement les yeux à dans la mise en
oeuvre de ces mandats technique et dans
quelques instants notre débat sur les
nouvelles règles du jeu dans
l'entreprise alors que le cadre
législatif régissant la vie des salariés
a évolué et les contraintes sont elles
moindre pour le chef d'entreprise elle
les salariés ont ils un cadre davantage
sécurisée nous en débattrons avec nos
invités rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
ou est-ce qu'on en est au niveau de la
radicalisation dans l'espoir que le
terme radicalisation c'est un peu un mot
valise et ont même beaucoup de choses
qui ne reflète pas la réalité lanta de
la radicalisation islamiste dans le
sport c'est tout ce processus qui peut
conduire quelqu'un à se mettre en marche
total de la société parfois même
basculer vers l'action violente en 2016
- sportif considéré que c'était pas son
affaire et qu'il n'avait pas à être en
une sorte de délateurs des pouvoirs plus
parce que le sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui
toute une série de phénomènes nous
échappe
ce sont ces associations qui se créent
ou bien des structures qui se créent en
dehors du mouvement organisé certains
ont dit le sport amateur c'est le
premier lieu vecteur de radicalisation
c'est faux c'est la prison dans les
clubs
il peut y avoir des cas de prosélytisme
mais pas contre les radicaliser ne vont
plus à la mosquée ne sont plus à l'école
ne sont plus dans les clubs retirer vos
de la tête le sport à 6 à 10
[Musique]
on
ces [ __ ] de bassorah qu'est-ce qui
coule des tuyaux larry page à la terre
voyez vous même ces lots de bassorah
vous avez été empoisonné par quoi
marleau vous jure c'est tout est en
train de nous tuer à saurat était
autrefois considérée comme la venise du
moyen-orient aujourd'hui la ville fait
face à la pire crise de l'eau de
l'histoire irakienne d'espèces cet
endroit était entouré de forêt de
palmiers à mon retour en 2003 j'étais
vraiment sous le choc c'est de l'eau du
robinet de bassorah elle a prétendument
été nettoyé
nous ne voulons qu'à verre d'eau pour
nos enfants et nous même si nous n'avons
pas d'eau nous n'avons rien l'or ou même
le pétrole n'auront plus aucun sens
l'eau et tout ce qui importe
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est le sentiment que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
ouais complètement vrai besoin
d'autonomie besoin de retourner à des
choses plus essentielles en fait est
vraiment de sentir qu'on n'est pas
forcément un poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi on a vu la serre les
plantes de vire avec les plantes comme
ça vraiment commune comme une machine un
organisme et pour fait partie de cet
organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps quand vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces gens de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage j'avais au camp sundance
c'est un conte pour les gens qui ne
peuvent pas être exposé au soleil ils me
disent c'est donc un camp pour les
vampires
je crois que c'est comme en centre
d'hébergement pour repère non pas à
parler de tout ce qu'ils traversent
parce que nous comprenons tous notre
fille katie a été diagnostiqué d'une
maladie très rare d'hypersensibilité au
soleil si j'ai un coup de soleil je
guéris elle elle ne guérit pas elles ont
aussi des problèmes moteurs des
problèmes d'élocution et d'audition ça
brise le volume du cerveau diminue
nettement insan le crâne grandi et le
cerveau rapetisse
il est impossible de décrire cette
douleur c'est comme une brûlure
chimiques très très grave
la douleur passe dans la peau et muscle
jusqu'aux os c'est impossible à soulager
parfois nous sommes mis à l'épreuve non
pour montrer nos faiblesses mais pour
découvrir nos forces
[Musique]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france merci de nous rejoindre
nouvelles statistiques en france le
nombre de chômeurs de catégorie a a
diminué de 3 3% en 2010 neuf il s'agit
de la plus forte baisse sur une année
depuis 10 ans est des chiffres qui
réjouissent le gouvernement mais qui
cache aussi de nombreuses disparités
regarde
[Musique]
on
bon
[Musique]
oh
220 salariés sur le carreau attaquent
leur employeur arjowiggins pour
licenciement sans cause réelle et
sérieuse et pourtant leurs entreprises
avaient été vendues en 2018 à deux fonds
germano suisse et pour faciliter cette
reprise la banque publique
d'investissement avait prêté 10 millions
d'euros mais les nouveaux employeurs
seraient partis avec la caisse une
actualité qui en rappellent d'autres et
qui interroge on en débat tout de suite
dans notre face à face et pour ce face à
face nous accueillons virginie pradel
présidente de l'institut vauban
fiscaliste bonsoir ça à vos côtés michel
henry avocat justement des salariés
d'arjowiggins donc je me tourne vers
vous dans cette affaire on à faire
acquis à un fait divers avec des ex
crowe ou alors c'est une affaire qui
révèle finalement plus que ça je crois
qu'on premier degré il ya eu un fait
divers un peu caricatural avec des gens
que le mandataire de justice a qualifiés
de bandes d'aigrefins qui ont repris
l'entreprise qu'ils ont pillé et qui ont
déposé le bilan très rapidement en
laissant de l'établissement industriel
qui n'avait plus aucun élément d'actif
mais au-delà de ces cinq derniers mois
de vie de cette entreprise qui n'est pas
à ce jour higgins et arjowiggins
security
c'était une filiale d'arjowiggins
spécialisée dans la fabrication de
papier sécurisé pour les cartes grises
passeports et billets de banques
deux étrangers il ya en arrière-plan
le groupe auquel appartenait cette
société qui est le groupe sequana dont a
joui d'une sécurité est une sous filiale
et ce groupe a fait un choix il ya une
dizaine d'années qui était d'abandonner
la filière papetière qui avait fait
l'histoire du groupe arjo et d'orienter
son activité ou sa recherche de profits
vers la distribution de papier c'est
l'autre moitié du sous groupe qui
s'appelle antalis et le le projet a été
réalisé par l'un fermetures successives
d'une dizaine de papeterie en france qui
constituait la force industrielle
d'argent alors c'est la maîtrise ont été
fermées les unes après les autres
wizernes dans le nord ils aident à faire
du mans à peu près en même temps que
carol higgins
mais avec néanmoins un plan social et un
plan social adossé aux capacités d'un
groupe qu'il en avait plus beaucoup de
capacités mais c'était quand même à un
groupe qui avait une certaine puissance
là l'opération a été particulièrement
pernicieuse parce qu'elle a consisté à
vider totalement les caisses de la
filiale arjowiggins à faire remonter
l'argent qui restait dans la société
mère ils ont notamment l'argent de la
vente des filiales d'arjowiggins
security et de une fois que la société a
été entièrement vidé de ses actifs de
trouver un repreneur
et alors ce dont on peut cette année
quand même c'est que cette reprise qui a
épargné au groupe sequana le coup d'un
plan social a reçu la bénédiction du
tribunal de commerce d'un administrateur
dans le cadre d'une procédure de
conciliation qui est une procédure très
secrète au tribunal de commerce
deux du ministère des finances de la
banque publique d'investissement est
l'interlocuteur de ce groupe de deux
personnes et de sociétés qui se
mettaient le le le consortium de reprise
d'arjowiggins
la principale personne qui était
l'interlocuteur à la fois des salariés
des dirigeants et bercy monsieur
terroristes c'est quelqu'un qui était
sous contrôle judiciaire et un gros qui
avait déjà été condamné par le tribunal
de commerce de versailles pour
banqueroute frauduleuse et donc
l'incompréhension c'est de savoir
comment on a pu ignorer
voilà le passé ou le présente cette
personne justement virginie pradal c'est
vrai que c'est vu une interrogation
c'est facile aujourd'hui pour une
personne qui a de l'argent de racheter
ce ce type de société sans contrôler ces
eaux vit dans un système comme celui ci
aujourd'hui mais c'est plus complexe et
a racheté des sociétés bon c'est très
fréquent ya pas de problème ce qui ce
qui confine à la mauvaise farce en fait
dans cette affaire comme l'a très bien
dit connaître et on dit michel henri
michel en risque si comme l'a très bien
dit voilà c'est que en fait ya une
conjonction d'événements ont peu farfelu
fondé des aides qui ont été octroyées et
ce sans contrôle et ça révèle quand même
que l'état n'est pas très prévenant dans
ce type d'affaires et que là on assiste
quand même à une gabegie assez
insupportable alors je vous propose
réagissent et puis après on va aller
plus loin on va laisser de côté ce cas
la vallée vous devez arrêter feu juste
apporter une précision c'est que on n'a
pas besoin d'argent pour acheter à
rejouer au bout d'une sécurité on en
reçoit de l'argent c'est à dire que le
prix de vente était négatif de 17
millions d'euros
donc on reçoit de l'argent donc au delà
de ce cas aujourd'hui au fond est-ce que
les contraintes pour les chefs
d'entreprise finalement sont moindres
que pour les salariés et est ce que
c'est une bonne chose selon vous
virginie pradal les contraintes sur les
chefs d'entravé non mais il ya quand
même beaucoup de contraintes ne faut pas
non plus faire un amalgame là c'était
défend de manière plus générale en
sortant de ce cas là est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les chefs d'entreprise
ont trop de contraintes suffisamment de
contraintes
oui il est évident qu'en france on n'est
quand même pas aidé quand on est chef
d'entreprise à savoir qu'on a quand même
une fiscalité assez oppressant et ce qui
nous distingue quand même de nombreux
pays voisins notamment l'allemagne
il ya quand même une pression fiscale
assez insupportable qui s'exerce sur les
entreprises françaises et notamment les
entreprises manufacturières ce qui
contribue bien évidemment à la
désindustrialisation de la france depuis
plusieurs décennies
c'est sûr que alors les faits divers se
succèdent mais même au niveau des
statistiques on constate que la part de
l'industrie manufacturière dans la
valeur ajoutée globale a chuté de
plusieurs points en 20 ans elle est
passée de plus de 16% à peu près 11 % ce
qui est moitié moins qu'en allemagne où
on atteint quasiment 23%
donc à un moment il faut se poser la
question et j'ai l'impression que
personne ne se la pose vraiment que
faire pour aider les entreprises et a
fortiori des industries manufacturières
qui comme on le sait participe
énormément au maintien de l'emploi dont
les territoires qui sont de plus en plus
des oeuvres et voilà est qui qui crée un
peu des poches de précarité dans notre
pays justement michel henry les salariés
que vous avez rencontré les salariés que
vous défendez qu'est-ce qu'il vous dise
on nous a pas défendu on nous a pas
assez défendu on n'est plus reconnue on
est plus à ses protégés ça passe par là
aussi le point de nos entreprises n'ont
eu que il veut dire des salariés
d'arjowiggins en particulier ils disent
rien ils ont vu venir ce qui s'est
produit l'ont dénoncé auprès du ministre
d'économie lequel écrit avant le dépôt
de bilan aux dirigeants pour leur dire
vous êtes en train de
conduire à la faillite cette entreprise
et vous le fait délibérément bon mais
l'aspect fiscal si vous voulez je n'ai
pas de connaissances particulières
ce que je vois c'est que le droit du
licenciement économique qui repose est
quand même sur un équilibre qui était de
tenir compte des réalités économiques
mais de ne pas licencier le personnel
pour accroître les profits
c'était un peu la ligne de démarcation
dans la loi la jurisprudence en or cette
protection dans le droit du licenciement
économique
c'est quand même largement effondré par
les facultés de contournement de ces
licenciements économiques
la succession des textes récents a
permis de développer les plans de
départs volontaires
les ruptures conventionnelles
collectives c'est-à-dire un ensemble de
mécanismes de rupture du contrat de
travail qui et ne nécessite pas de
contraintes importantes et qui ne
permettent pas ensuite de contestation
non plus devant le conseil des
prud'hommes donc il ya des départs
massifs dans les entreprises qui se font
souvent sur la base d'un apparent
volontariat avec les incitations
financières
et tout cela je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse dire que ça crée beaucoup de
contraintes 1 alors il ya un plus un
autre phénomène c'est que le droit de la
faillite
lui est utilisé pour faciliter les
restructurations industrielles en ce
sens que ces contraintes qui se sont
amoindries ces dernières années elle
n'existe presque plus du tout dans le
droit de la faillite vous déposer le
bilan
le mandataire de justice n'a que
quelques jours pour faire mener est ce
il ya plus d'argent dans la caisse il
peut pas en inventer la société
appartenait à un groupe elle
n'appartient plus à ce groupe
souvent et les protections du droit du
travail sur la continuité des contrats
de travail si on trouve un repreneur ne
s'applique plus non plus obligatoirement
donc il ya une je dirais de certaines
formes d'attraction vers l'utilisation
du droit de la faillite pour pour
faciliter les restructurations et
licencier du personnel
virginie pradal vous partager ce que
vient de dire michel henry à savoir à
déséquilibre finalement entre le le
salarié et puis et puis finalement ceux
qui peuvent racheter mettre en faillite
utiliser le droit du travail au fonds à
des fins personnelles vous avez bien
entendu mais les salariés sont les
victimes de tout cela en france 1 c'est
vraiment et les maillons faibles
malheureusement c'est quoi c'est un
manque de volonté des politiques selon
vous c'est en fait le système assez
paradoxale où l'état
communique énormément sur toutes les
aides qui sont attribués aux industriels
et qui sont réels mais qui ne sont pas
très contrôlée comme la cette affaire le
révèle mais de l'autre côté l'état ne
fait que compenser par ne fait que
compenser les problèmes qu'il génère lui
même en créant une déréglementation
toujours plus complexes et des impôts
toujours plus important parce que
rappelons que en france on est quand
même taxé avant d'avoir fait des
bénéfices bien sûr faut distinguer
différentes choses là la sphère qui est
en cause est une arnaque
enfin grossières alors qu'ils sont la
lgv à l'allemand là non plus se
focaliser que sur cette affaire pour
parler des problèmes industriels en
france mais force est de constater que
il ya quand même des velléités
politiques pour réindustrialiser la
france et refaire de notre pays une
force d'attraction en matière
industrielle
alors je vous propose maintenant
d'écouter fiodor rilov c'était l'avocat
des salariés de l'usiné vous diront
souvient il s'est exprimé hier sur le
plateau de polypes mag on l'écouté au
réagir ensuite vous savez qu'il ya eu
plusieurs réformes du code du travail
elle a été fermée ya six ans absolument
et que dans cet intervalle entre 2014 et
aujourd'hui hollande et macron honte
enlever du code du travail
quasiment tous les articles sur le
fondement desquels les salariés de
goodyear font le procès aux prud'hommes
c'est à dire que hollande et macron on
était le code du travail pardon j'ai un
peu triviale pour que des groupes comme
goodyear puisse licencier désormais sans
entrave
michel henry une réaction le code du
travail pour permettre aux enfants de ne
pas payer
vous rejoignez cette analyse je ne
nierai pas chercher les intentions
cachées des auteurs de ces réformes mais
elles vont toutes dans le même sens ce
qui est dedans - drire les garanties des
salariés 2
réduire les possibilités de recours de
rendre ces recours
difficile est illusoire dans la mesure
où les possibilités de percevoir une
indemnisation à la mesure de son
préjudice ont disparu par l'effet du
barème macron et si on ajoute à ça que
dans le cas de la faillite des faillites
impécunieuse comme y'en a beaucoup celle
là en particulier c'est le fonds de
garantie des créances salariales qui
finit par recevoir l'addition
puisqu'elle n'est pas payée par
l'entreprise en faillite
le fonds de garantie ne paye qu'à
hauteur de plafond pour simplifier le
plus élevé de ces plafonds
c'est à peu près 80 mille euros en brut
mais il faut savoir que dans ces
entreprises le fonds de garantie quand
il est sollicité pour payer des
condamnations il a déjà avancé de
l'argent
il a déjà avancé des derniers salaires
jusqu'à la date du licenciement ils à
payer les indemnités de licenciement et
le préavis est par conséquent il n'ya
plus que la marge disponible entre le
plafond est ce qu'il a déjà payé qui
peut couvrir une condamnation alors là
c'est même plus le barème macron c'est
la marge résiduelles et le paradoxe
c'est que plus les salariés ans
d'ancienneté
- cette marge est importante puisque
leurs indemnités de rupture sont plus
importantes que ceux qui ont moins
d'ancienneté de telle sorte que pour
simplifier par exemple dans la sphère
arjowiggins les cadres n'ont plus de
marge disponible pour la plupart ils ont
tous reçu une indemnisation de la gs
hauteur de la totalité de ce qui peut
être couvert par la chaise et même les
ouvriers ils ont généralement une marge
disponible de garantie de la gs qui se
situe entre 150 et 300 milles entre
15000 et rang et 30000 euros ce qui est
dérisoire au regard de destruction de
leur emploi et leur situation
personnelle virginie pradal est ce que
il y a une volonté d' à moins
ir les garanties des salariés
aujourd'hui selon vous ouais bah de
toute manière c'est factuel sur volonté
politique et une volonté politique je
pense que dans la logique de macron qui
est celle de rendre la france un peu
plus compétitive
forcément tous les cas
vous voyez des entreprises condamnées à
payer de lourdes indemnités à des
salariés faisait mauvais effet à
l'étranger donc je pense que ça va dans
le sens de rendre la france plus
attractives ont malheureusement ça se
fait clairement au détriment des
salariés c'est le salarié la variable
d'ajustement aujourd'hui à totalement
totalement
il faudrait éviter d'en arriver là
monsieur henry oui l'ont toujours été
mais je veux dire ils le sont d'autant
plus facilement que qu'il ya moins de
protection pour garantir la stabilité de
l'emploi et que les licenciements sont
plus faciles ce que disait fiodor rilov
tout à l'heure c'est exact mais dans la
sphère goodyear les salariés ont touché
le montant des dommages et intérêts qui
leur ont été accordées alors que dans la
sphère arjowiggins il et toucheront pas
en plus sain et mettons que le conseil
des prud'hommes leur accord de cinquante
ou soixante mille euros de dommages et
intérêts ce qui ne remplacera pas leur
emploi qu'ils ont perdu et bien la
garantie résiduelle de la gs ne couvrira
que qu'entre une petite autres rien et
puis vingt ou trente mille euros sur le
sens montant là ça peut être quelque
chose qui deviendrait la norme plus tard
selon vous un génie pradel par rapport à
ce que vous observez parce que je
constate de façon globale ces combats
vers une précarisation de l'emploi
je vous donne un élément tout simple le
gouvernement énormément communiqué sur
la flambée de la crypte en des créations
d'entreprises en fait qu'est ce que ça
cache sa cache une flambée
de la création de micro-entreprises
alors la micro entreprise a été créée
avec de très bonnes intentions
malheureusement ce dispositif un peu
était pas et même beaucoup été perverti
et et qu'est ce qu'on constate
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui sont obligées de recourir
à ce dispositif parce qu'elles ne
peuvent plus être salarié parce que les
entreprises veulent faire des économies
ne veulent pas prendre des risques
donc tout ça contribue à une sorte de
précarisation exacerbée à on le voit la
nouvelle économie et une économie
précaire où on bénéficie alors ni de
céder in its et des impasses que le
gouvernement essaie de combattre les cdd
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est même
plus le prince s'est clairement pu le
problème le problème c'est d'avoir un
emploi et de ne pas recourir à des
dispositifs extrêmement précaire et ce
qu'ils font
ce à quoi il faut faire attention c'est
la communication du gouvernement par
exemple le gouvernement communique
énormément sur la baisse du taux du
chômage bon relativisons on est quand
même le pays de l'union européenne par
le quatrième et de l'union européenne
qui a le taux de chômage le plus élevé
on est à plus de 8% quand la moyenne au
sein de l'union européenne est à 6% et
qu'en allemagne on est à 3 %
donc on est quand même dans un pays qui
reste encore en proie à des vraies
difficultés économiques
je vous propose d'écouter maintenant
xavier mathieu c'était le porte celle
porte-parole de la cgt continental
il réagissait hier un toujours d'un
polype mag sur un autre quart
emblématique celui de continental il y a
dix ans sept ans de combat pour faire le
reconnaîtra le caractère abusif de leur
licenciement pour ses salariés
je vous propose d'écouter et xavier
mathieu porte-parole de la cgt
continental et ce qui est terrible c'est
que aujourd'hui les conti encore plus de
la moitié des mecs qui sont à la rue
compass de travail et en ayant eu des
indemnités assez colossal à l'époque on
avait réussi à se battre on a réussi à
avoir tous que avec les lois macron les
gens ne pourront plus avoir ce qui veut
dire c'est que les gens aujourd'hui onze
ans après il y en a la moitié dans la
merde
et encore on a réussi à se battre et à
obtenir des indemnités qui ont fait que
les gens le temps a duré était un peu
moins dure le temps de voir les gens à
l'avenir là ils vont se faire virer et
en plus avec rien voilà xavier mathieu
l'ancien porte-parole de la cgt
continental on l'entendait ils vont se
faire virer et avec rien dix ans après
puisqu'il ya eu entre temps des réformes
vous l'expliquez comment michel henry
savait ce ses observations pour penser
une vieille jurisprudence qui est l
affaire cricket ou avant que la
législation sur le licenciement
économique ne soit tout à fait défini il
ya une entreprise qui avait
appelé les salariés à se présenter à la
direction pour toucher un chèque
s'il partait volontairement de
l'entreprise en plus les gens étaient
endosser endetté plus ils se sont
précipités pour aller prendre le chèque
et on a retrouvé deux ans plus tard tous
ces gens qui étaient partis avec un
chèque et un départ volontaire en
surendettement est dans la misère leurs
maisons vendues et ea la rue alors la
jurisprudence avait mis fin
pendant un certain temps à ces pratiques
en considérant que tout départ qui
s'inscrivait dans des motifs économiques
devaient être soumis à la législation
sur le licenciement économique mais
c'est ça qui est aujourd'hui détruit de
manière non pas tout à fait total mais
largement à travers ces mécanismes de
nouveau de plan de départs volontaires
alors avec un minimum de forme une
consultation du comité d'entreprise
une un accompagnement qui est celui des
licenciements économiques
mais enfin le résultat il est que les
gens qui sont le plus en difficulté sont
ceux qui ont le plus besoin le plus
immédiat d'argent et qui sont le plus
tenté de répondre à ces invitations à
partir avec un chèque
alors maintenant s'il fallait se
demander si le gouvernement suit une
logique de déstructuration du code du
travail je crois que ce qui s'est passé
au mois de décembre on est un exemple
flagrant
il ya une loi qui a été votée sans qu'on
y prête beaucoup d'attention qui
permettait aux plateformes savait que
je ris présence et la cour de cassation
ont récemment jugé que les salariés des
plates formes qui font les services de
livraison à domicile par exemple de
repas en fait avec un contrat de travail
en voilà alors qu'on les considérait
comme des des zooms claude et des gens
qui étaient des travailleurs
indépendants et le gouvernement a fait
voter un texte homme qui a été censuré
par le conseil constitutionnel et qui
prévoyait que c'était les plateformes
qui définissait eu elle-même les règles
de droit social qu'elle entendait
appliquer et que pour autant qu'elle
définisse une charte en ce sens dont
elle était libre de déterminer le
contenu est bien les salariés ne
pourrait jamais revendiqué l'existence
d'un contrat de travail à l'heure n'a
trouvé que c'était un peu trop ça a été
censuré je vous propose d'écouter
maintenant alexis poulain cofondateur du
monde moderne est pour lui le
gouvernement n'a pas de projet pour
l'industrie en france si ce n'est que
l'objectif c'est de nettoyer le monde
ouvrier on les écoute il n'y a pas de
plan en fait pour l'industrie en france
il n'y en a jamais eu à vrai dire il ya
un plan par contre c'est pour effacer et
et enlever le monde ouvrier des radars
parce que derrière
depuis toujours le monde ouvrier celle
d'angers en politique c'est le monde
syndical c'est le monde qui ait pas
d'accord avec les règles des riches et
et ça se voit et c'est devenu pourquoi
aujourd'hui il ya cette ce désamour
aussi de l'industrie c'est que pendant
des années on dit que ce n'était pas une
filière s'étaient pas un emploi c'était
un coin de garage
ouais vous vous étiez mauvais à l'école
et ben se faisait une formation s'était
pas quelque chose qui était une carrière
virginie pradal une réaction aux ses
propos d'alexis poulain effectivement on
n'a pas de plan d'industrie aujourd'hui
et l'idée c'est de supprimer les
ouvriers oui ça c'est sûr qu'on n'a pas
de vision industrielle en france et ce
depuis plusieurs décennies
mais gageons qu'on va remédier à ce
problème bientôt même si j'ai pas
vraiment l'impression qu'on soit sûr que
ça doit
c'est vrai qu'il ya des choses assez
juste le fait qu'on n'ait pas vraiment
valoriser les filières manufacturière ça
c'est aussi une évidence un il ya quand
même une voilà beaucoup de une vision
très négative partagé pendant plusieurs
années
bon après je pense pas non plus que ce
soit l'intention du gouvernement de
détruire la classe ouvrière là je trouve
que c'est quand même un petit peu
excessif ce qui se passe malheureusement
c'est que bas en france on a un modèle
social qu'il faut lé fine enfin qui doit
être financée qui est énormément financé
par les entreprises et notamment par les
cotisations sociales patronales
ce qui fait que malheureusement on a une
industrie qui est faible parce que trop
coûteuse par rapport aux industries
d'autres pays concurrents on est dans un
système ultra concurrentielle où ils
traquent concurrentiel pardon au sein de
l'union européenne on vous parle même
pas dans le monde c'est encore pire si
on prend par exemple la chine et que
aujourd'hui on n'est pas du tout armé
pour lutter contre ces pays parce qu on
est trop lourd et et voilà qu'on n'a pas
fait des choix très pertinent et que
l'état n'aide pas suffisamment à mon
sens les entreprises qui sont dans des
territoires et qui sont qui sont
enfermés les unes après les autres avec
des conséquences sociales et économiques
désastreuses comme on le sait michel
henry ne reste que quelques secondes
un mot pour conclure le gouvernement de
rêve t-il faire davantage pour les
salariés pourraient déjà arrêter de
détruire le code du travail
ce serait déjà beaucoup merci beaucoup à
tous les deux merci virginie pradel je
rappelle que vous êtes présidente de
l'institut global fiscaliste merci à
vous michel henry rappelle que vous êtes
avocat des salariés d'arjowiggins
security c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
dans 5 minutes pour 1 point complet sur
l'actualité à tout
[Musique]
à
la rivière tout boy chiot au delà du
cours moyen
et elle s'est inclinée pour saluer le
propriétaire du tchoum la tente
traditionnelle et à la demande et fait
cesser cette tempête de neige sinon mon
peuple mourra
[Musique]
pourquoi vraiment nollywood est née au
nigeria et pas par exemple au sénégal au
mali